seeing all these people
of all walks of life different races
different creeds different sexual
orientations all this
doing great things together and then to
have
our government come in and say the
military has an extremism problem it's a
slap in the face
extremism and extremism extremism in the
us military i want to understand
working to root out extremism in our
nation's military today
give military leaders the chance to
address extremism not new to our country
and sadly
it's not new to our military military
really hasn't done that much at the
moment to find out okay who might be
affiliated with these groups
[Music]
i served in the us army from 1997 to
2017
20 years uh i retired as a master
sergeant i come from military family
both my grandfathers from the navy my
dad was in the army my older brother was
in the army um
but really for me was to just get out of
the house and start adventuring and
living my life all total i spent 54
months in iraq or afghanistan
that time period for me
um
was kind of like
warp speed
it went very fast
something that's different in the
military
other than other places in the world is
that you're no longer important
right like
you as an individual are not important
the mission is important and your
teammates are important right like you
always put your teammate before yourself
i could i could go back throughout my
entire career and tell you i don't know
anyone who i served with stances on
abortion i don't know any of their
stances on
i don't name another hot button domestic
issue we didn't care
that was for you right i had my one vote
everybody in the unit had their one vote
that was our that was our part in the
political system
as an organization it's a political it's
it's never gonna do things for the
benefit of a particular political party
but
you know i do think that a lot of the
decisions are
made or not made
by a lot of the higher level
brass like generals um
with politics in mind
when you get into that general officer
area you know you don't want to rock the
boat
maybe um
with whoever is currently in office or
who you think will be in office come
time for you to retire and look for your
look for your you know million dollar a
year job at halliburton they're setting
themselves up they're not doing what's
right for the force they're not doing
they're not doing their job of
protecting
that private on the line who's been in
the army for six months which is their
job to make policy
that protects the military right that
keeps their best interest at heart that
makes sure that they're only committed
to things
that they need to be committed to and
that once they're committed to it that
they're supported fully and that's
something that hasn't happened in a very
long time how to combat extremism in the
military a growing concern we've
highlighted on this show for many many
months investigators have revealed that
dozens in the mob that stormed the
capital on january 6 had ties to the u.s
military the pentagon is now trying a
new effort to address extremism in its
ranks lloyd austin ordering a
service-wide stand down for the next 60
days the goal
give military leaders the chance to
address extremism in the ranks the
military is an environment with the
least amount of extremism
by far
of anything we have in america people
come from all walks of life to come to
the military
i think that you probably saw people
that came in
with some of those views they were
racist they were sexist they were
homophobic
but after
it didn't take long for him to lose it
all of the all of the kind of ignorance
that leads to extremist behavior
it's squashed because you're
you're immersed in all these other
cultures you're immersed with all these
other types of people from a marine
corps base in california to an air force
base in texas our purpose is to address
a concern
that has likely been around for decades
and has either been dormant or simply
ignored on the 5th of february in 2021
the secretary of defense directed a
service-wide and dod wide stand down to
address the issues of extremist ideology
in our ranks
make no mistake extremist behaviors have
no place in our navy or our navy reserve
but i can't ignore its existence in our
military the events of january 6
underscored the necessity to engage in
serious discussions about the behaviors
and actions that undermine the
democratic ideals of our nation
seeing all these people
of all walks of life different races
different creeds different sexual
orientations all this doing great things
together and then to have
our government come in and say the
military has an extremism problem it's a
slap in the face and it
it makes me upset i'm not i'm not saying
that we're above you know investigation
we should always make sure we're on the
right path but for it to be such a an
open
like
thing for the them to come out say we
have an extremism problem because of 75
dum-dums who went to the capitol
um
it's an insult it's an insult to all
those people that are out there doing
the right thing i couldn't tell you what
the motivation is to say that it's this
huge overarching wide problem if it if
it was a problem
it was an outlier
and i can say that
policy within the army that i can speak
of
had all the tools it needed to just
squash it
the 21-page report on handling protest
extremist and criminal gang activities
among members of the armed forces
recommends the defense department revise
its recruiting screening and transition
materials and strengthen its vetting and
insider threat programs the pentagon
would not give a breakdown of the 100
extremists identified during the past
year out of more than 2 million active
duty service members
the fact that that
investigation came up with less than 100
instances of extremism in the military
makes me wonder why there was
there was an investigation in the first
place
i'm not worried um about our
our ability to fight a near-pier war
against russia or china or anybody
i think we'll
because we're american i think we're
going to figure it out
but again i know we're going to figure
it out
i just want
our people that are currently serving to
have
all the time and energy and resources
they need and for us to be
focusing organizational energy within
the military on problems that don't
exist
is worrisome